[Music]
on this Sunday night what's being called
the greatest World Cup final ever
Lionel Messi's moment the most important
thing is that Messi has the cup and he
will bring it to Argentina The crucial
penalty kick
[Applause]
and how Argentina got the World Cup it
wanted the horrors of War hit home we
were sort of their last hope as a
Canadian volunteer medical team returns
after helping soldiers from Ukraine the
January 6th panel wraps up charging a
former president with crimes like
Insurrection or obstruction would be
completely unprecedented could this
complicate Trump's 2024 run block by
block the Lego menorah lighting up the
first night of Hanukkah
global national with para Nasser
[Applause]
and there it is the thunderous moment of
pure joy in Buenos Aires after a soccer
final for the ages in Qatar for the
first time in 36 years Argentina has won
the FIFA World Cup their team triumphed
after an absolutely nail-biting final
that kept Millions around the world at
the edge of their seats the roller
coaster match saw France come back from
a two-nothing deficit then both teams
trading goals and tying the scoreboard
until The Bitter End when Argentina
sealed its victory in penalty shots
good evening and thank you for joining
us this match is already being hailed as
one of the most thrilling matches in
World Cup history if not all of soccer
itself but for one player one of the
greatest in the sport fate finally found
its way into this Final in our top story
tonight Mike drolet on how Lionel Messi
got the magical moment the world wanted
him to have
[Music]
if this is the final chapter in Lionel
Messi's International career oh what a
way to go out the 35 year old had won
everything there is to collect in soccer
except this
are you doing
in Buenos Aires argentinians screamed
cried held babies Aloft in the air
and like this young woman simply became
overcome with joy
billions around the world anxiously
watched Argentina go up early and
collapse late before ultimately edging
injury ravaged France in a sensational
shootout
for every emotional Peak
came a corresponding Valley
one of the greatest World Cup finals of
all time it sure had it all
nine-year-old Astor budzio rode the wave
with fans in Toronto's West End there
are no guarantees in soccer but on this
day his Idol Messi the role model for
Millions worldwide came through yeah
I've been wanting to be a soccer player
since it's unless since I'm a kid and uh
I guess a win for my country is very
good big kids pretty excited too
it felt at times like again we weren't
just watching soccer we were watching
theater Canadian journalist Joshua cloak
cause watching Messi play three times in
Qatar a career and life highlight but
what he found most mesmerizing happened
off the pitch the way that that people
treat Lionel Messi and and by people I
mean fans but I also mean journalists
they Revere him in a way that I have
truly never seen a nation Revere an
athlete and that's saying something
considering the way Argentina deified
former World Cup hero Diego Maradona the
messy murals throughout Buenos Aires are
already too numerous to count after
winning the World Cup it's a safe bet
there will soon be many more microwave
Global News Toronto
and as we mentioned although Argentina's
win was a long time coming this is not
the first time they've grasped World Cup
Glory
the country first won when they hosted
soccer's biggest tournament back in 1978
defeating the Netherlands in the final
on home soil but it was their 1986 World
Cup performance in Mexico that entered
into sports legend that's when soccer
great dioga Maradona scored what's
considered two of the greatest goals in
history the goal of the century and the
hand of God both within mere minutes of
each other during the quarterfinal
Argentina went on to win that tournament
as well
Ukrainian president vlodimir zielinski
was hoping his new appeal for peace
would be broadcast ahead of today's
World Cup final that did not happen but
he's still pushing for a Global Peace
Summit this winter in a video message
shared on social media zielinski draws
inspiration from the World Cup and
soccer's ability to unite the world he
says there are no champions in war there
can be no draw
This World Cup proved time and again
that different countries and
nationalities can decide who is the
strongest in the fair play but not in
the playing with fire on the green
playing field and not on the red
Battlefield
many people around the world are doing
everything they can to help Ukraine
especially at this time of year they're
offering gifts sharing time and praying
for peace one Canadian medical team of
volunteers just returned from a mission
in Poland where they provided crucial
surgical care emotional support and hope
for the future
Julia Foy met up with the team there and
reports on the difference they made
as Russia continues to bomb civilian
communities and Destroy critically
important infrastructure in Ukraine
thousands of people have died many more
left with broken bodies and shattered
lives
earlier this month some injured patients
were transported to a trauma Hospital in
Poland for special care provided by a
volunteer medical team from the Canada
Ukraine Foundation all of them both the
military civilian patients had
devastating injuries resulting from
artillery fire from sniper fire from
mines explosive injuries and so on
35 Medical experts from across Canada
spent days working in operating rooms
usually from Sunrise until after
midnight many of the patients needing
medical attention are Ukrainian soldiers
for their security were not identifying
them these unfortunate Heroes here have
been injured in the battlefield they've
had trauma many of them have had
multiple surgeries on their here there
are civilian casualties as well like
ulana a grandmother of four
she says there was an explosion in the
house she has injuries to her legs her
arm and her eyes she's now had 12
surgeries to date
33 year old Oxana asked us not to show
her face disfigured by a missile strike
on her home her 13 year old son was
killed in the attack
she found her son slumped in a chair and
shrapnel from a missile instantly killed
him she heard her daughter calling and
found her covered in blood she survived
for the Canadian volunteers the horrors
these patients have endured hit home too
my mother was from Eastern Ukraine from
luhans and my father was
from the West
so for me this is very heartfelt I
believe most of them have also lost
family members and children
on the final day as doctors come to say
goodbye Oksana agrees to show us her new
face
she's very thankful and says her
daughter is very happy the Canadian
Ukraine Foundation is now planning
another medical mission in March if
there are enough donations and
volunteers to support them I'm just in
awe with how much good we've done here
and how much we're going to keep doing
because we're going to keep coming back
we're sort of their last hope so it was
very important that we deliver on our
promise to provide
appropriate care to them
and is extremely extremely gratifying
when we could uh do so these Canadian
doctors and Health Care Professionals
are trading their front lines of crisis
in Canada for the front lines of
conflict a world away offering something
desperately needed healing and Hope
Julia Foy Global News shallads Poland
many Ukrainian refugees will be spending
their first holiday here in Canada but
Advocates across the country are ramping
up calls for Ottawa to do more to
support Afghan refugees a recently
launched program for private sponsor
applications has quickly filled up and
it's a crushing blow to those helping
vulnerable Afghans with no other option
and as nithu garcha reports some say
there's a double standard depending on
what country you come from
I don't want to have the fear of losing
my family it's very scary Ray azimi is
an Afghan Canadian desperate to help her
relatives currently stuck in Turkey
after what she says were direct threats
from the Taliban they've left their jobs
behind they've worked in the Afghanistan
government
and they cannot go back because their
lives are in danger that it's a constant
fear of getting deported Sophia hamayun
is also a Canadian citizen with
relatives including a former journalist
who escaped to Tajikistan shortly after
the Taliban takeover she's also an
immigration consultant this particular
case shook me so much she says in one
case the brother of an Afghan
interpreter who helped the Canadian
military was deported back to
Afghanistan because of a technicality he
left in June of 2021 instead of July
he's living in hiding we don't know if
he's that are alive so you know we have
countless cases like this hamayun says
she knows Canada can't help every
vulnerable Afghan but she believes the
Canadian government's treatment of them
highlights a double standard we have
resettled I believe it's 100 128
000 ukrainians and 400 000 applications
have been approved and when we look at
the Afghan resettlement that we have
that we have brought into Canada from
August 2021 until present it's the
number is only 26 000. the federal
government has multiple streams of
applications available for private
sponsors to apply for Afghans who don't
have official Refugee status sources
tell Global News the latest stream
launched in October filled up within
hours it was capped at only 3 000
Afghans unlike similar programs for
syrians in 2015. do we need to God
forbid see another Alan Kerdi on the
shore in order for us to realize the
depth of the series of the Afghan
Refugee crisis why is the Afghan faced
with this kind of differential treatment
I don't get it is a mystery to me and
the government must lift the cap to
bring people to safety NDP immigration
critic Jenny Kwan says the average
processing time for privately sponsored
refugees is four years I continue to
receive
ongoing emails and contacts from people
to say I served Canada we're not giving
up on these folks uh the challenges that
exist inside the country are like
nothing that we've ever seen on any
resettlement initiative the federal
immigration Minister says the door is
open for increasing the caps on various
sponsorship streams we need to be the
advocate for change as well and those
like azimi are urging the Canadian
public to join them in their plea to
urge the government to make the
necessary changes now nitu karcha global
news
the clock is ticking on the United
Nations biodiversity conference in
Montreal cop 15 is set to wrap up
tomorrow but after nearly two weeks of
negotiations among 196 countries there's
still no agreement as Mike Armstrong
reports there are signs one could be
coming
goal of this convention in the words of
the head of the United Nations is to
reach a peace pact with nature well that
peace pact has a final draft China is
presiding over cop 15 and Sunday morning
released a proposed text the challenge
now is to get the negotiators from the
Nations gathered to sign on this is my
22nd or 23rd cop when you combine
climate and bio biodiversity I've never
seen that before the text agreement
includes the 30 by 30 Target countries
would agree to protect 30 percent of the
globe by 2030. the fact there's
agreement on that is being applauded by
environmental groups although some are
calling for the text to be more specific
instead of listing simply land fresh
water and oceans they want it specified
that it's 30 percent of each the ocean
they say is too often ignored without
healthy ocean there is no chance for a
healthy Planet the ocean is 70 percent
of our life support system
another important part of the deal is
financial the text sets a target of 200
billion dollars a year for conservation
initiatives a sticking point
negotiations has been that some
developing countries want more wealthy
Nations to pay a bigger share well
environmentalists say 200 billion likely
isn't enough while it is certainly a
major increase over past it doesn't
reach the level that we thought is
needed and finance is critical for
implementation the conference enters its
final day Monday with some optimism
there are still details to iron out and
close to 200 negotiating teams to get on
side but things do appear to be further
along than many predicted going in
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
the January 6 committee findings come
out this week coming up what to watch
for and what it means for Donald Trump
[Music]
after conducting more than a thousand
interviews and reviewing hours of
footage the January 6 committee will
issue its final report this week on the
attack on the U.S Capitol the committee
will reportedly recommend the Department
of Justice File criminal charges against
former president Donald Trump for his
role in the attack Trump though already
firing back Jennifer Johnson has the
latest
after making its case through mountains
of evidence and at times dramatic Prime
Time testimony the house January 6
committee will make its final Public
Presentation Monday it's expected to
vote to recommend the justice department
pursue criminal charges against former
president Donald Trump I think members
have become uh convinced that there's
value in it committee members say the
gravity of their action is not lost on
them at least three extraordinary
charges against Trump are being
considered Insurrection obstruction of
an official proceeding and conspiracy to
defraud the U.S government charging a
former president with crimes like
Insurrection or obstruction would be
completely unprecedented time is running
out for the committee to hold Trump
accountable because Republicans take
control of the house early next year the
committee has been under tremendous time
pressure that they are going to be
dissolved by the new with the new
Congress which starts on January 3rd
the committee alleges Trump helped
orchestrate the assault we fight like
hell while pressuring various State
officials Justice Department officials
and vice president Mike Pence himself a
target of right or violence to overturn
the election results this is someone who
tried to interfere with a joint session
uh even inciting a mob to attack the
capital
if that's not criminal then uh
then I don't know what it is Trump is
already striking back telling supporters
on his truth social platform they are
going after me because they are really
going after you criminal charges could
complicate Trump's bid to regain the
White House and further alienate himself
from Republican leaders some of whom may
face their own ethics investigations for
defying January 6 committee subpoenas
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
a 19 year old man has been charged with
people smuggling in the UK ibrahima will
appear in court on Monday for his role
and facilitated attempted illegal to the
country earlier this week four people
died and dozens of others had to be
rescued from the English Channel when
the small boat they were traveling in
capsized the major rescue operation
involved coordination between British
and French Navy's police and the Coast
Guard at least 45 thousand migrants were
attempted and refugees have attempted
the English Channel Crossing in the past
year
[Music]
I had the plight of political prisoners
in Iran the action Iranian and Canadians
want Ottawa to take
[Music]
Iranian Canadians are calling on leaders
in Ottawa to take a stand on behalf of
thousands imprisoned for protesting
against the regime in Iran two people
have already been executed in a brutal
Crackdown by the Islamic Republic others
await their fate on death row nagar
mojadi has the story
who should I mourn for more these are
the many Iranian protesters on death row
among them teenage boy Odin farzonia an
Iranian Soccer Star Amir Nas azodani and
radiologist Dr Hamid Farah Hassan Lu
these are not just numbers these are
human beings Vancouver resident golnos
vachari is overcome with grief when the
first executions happened it was as if
someone just took out something
underneath me I couldn't breathe I
couldn't think I was paralyzed the
execution of Iranian protesters without
any legal representation evidence or
chosen legal counsel is tearing her
apart
but she's transforming her pain into
action pleading with Canadian MPS to
become political sponsors of Iranian
political prisoners most of whom are in
danger of imminent execution on bogus
charges the MP will take responsibility
for one or two prisoners
um they raised awareness about them they
keep track on the news about them they
urge their own governments to fight for
their release MP Harry fry says she's
considering and believes this is
something Canadian MPS can do we are
feeling the Deep connection to the
Iranian Community the idea of political
sponsorship started with members of
parliament in Germany
leading the cause with her sponsorship
of rapper too much salahi we are
watching very closely what they are
doing we can change stuff so we can like
use our mandate to to do something and
change the life also of those people so
we should do it and MP in Frankfurt just
sponsored Dr Karen Hassan Lu and his
wife farzane welcome news to Iranian
Canadian Doctor moshdaba yakrang safakar
Who has been friends with Dr Gara Hassan
Lu for 30 years he you know
presented before George with broken ribs
he was healthy when he was arrested what
he don't see in the court is justice
that drive for justice is what motivates
golnas when you're dealing with a regime
like the Islamic Republic that doesn't
play by any International rules when you
find a firm ground to make them
accountable you have to take it neggar
Mo Shahidi Global News
[Music]
next the building blocks for Menorah we
take you to one special Hanukkah
celebration
[Music]
it was a snowy start of the week leading
up to Christmas for British Columbians
today as an arctic front move through
the province it's not entirely caused
for holiday cheer of course on top of
the icy temperatures there are snowfall
warnings for part of the province some
are facing up to 20 centimeters
blanketing communities poor road
conditions and low visibility have also
caused traffic chaos
the first night of Hanukkah will arrive
this evening and many people across the
globe will be celebrating by lighting
the menorah
across Canada cities and local
communities are planning holiday
ceremonies the festival of light follows
a strict ritual with one candle being
lit each day the center Candle is lit
together with the first candle and it
stays lit throughout the holiday this
year is the year of huckle which happens
once every seven years and it puts a
special focus on Humanity
and speaking of Hanukkah an important
symbol was also given a fun spin at an
Amer at an Ontario community center
Brick by Brick
in Vaughn this 10-foot tall Menorah was
built entirely out of Lego for the
annual celebrations following its
construction done with the help of
families in attendance a lighting
ceremony also took place the Lego
Menorah consisted of over 5 000 pieces
and was built to give children a unique
memory
and happy Hanukkah to those of you
celebrating that's global national for
this Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser and
on behalf of our whole crew I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's here
Canada is the chickadee checking out a
is this chickadee I should say checking
out a Christmas ornament in Calgary
Alberta we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing us those photos at
viewers at globalnational.com Donna will
be back with you tomorrow until next
time take care of yourselves and each
other good night
foreign
[Music]
foreign